[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements]
je dis soit dis
juste soit je
dis ni l'un ni l'autre je ne peux pas dire ni ni ni ni l'un ni l'autre, mettons
tout cela de côté
rattrapez-moi
excusez-moi miam
bonsoir Eddie hé Mme Chen bonsoir
venin
Mme Chen il dit
salut, c'est le numéro le plus solitaire que tu auras
jamais fait, je veux dire penser à toi
[Musique]
toi et moi sommes pareils à
chaque décision que
nous prenons
[Musique]
qui laissons-nous derrière nous
et comment pouvons-nous les laisser
attendre dans l'obscurité
le  sauveur qui ne vient jamais
[Applaudissements]
bon retour Eddie Brock
ça fait longtemps
tu me manques
tellement
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
bientôt le chaos le
chaos
bientôt arrivé
la livraison de chocolat n'est pas
encore arrivée non nous avions un accord, qu'est-ce qui va
t'arriver'  je vais arrêter de me protéger je suis
content de manger Mme Chen non non tu ne peux pas
manger Mme Chen quoi de
rien
toi